good morning Hank it's Tuesday my wife
is a Yeti my dog is a pirate and I am a
semi-professional video blogger Hank do
you ever wonder how this all like
happened right so Hank we have a hundred
thousand subscribers let me try to put
that in context for you that means that
if each of our subscribers gave us $100
we could potentially buy a private
island in the ocean and make
nerdfighteria a real country so even
though the nerdfighters haven't bought
us an island yet we still like them a
lot
and so in my last video I asked them
what we could get them to say thanks and
here are some of their real suggestions
online hip hop collaboration between a
Hank and Natalie from community channel
yes yes yes Hank
nerdfighters make that happen do another
tour to nerdfighting okay I promise that
we will do another tour to nerdfighting
but it takes a lot of like planning and
logistics and money so it may be a while
but it will happen by each of your
subscribers and iPod yeah that's a great
idea except first most of our
subscribers probably already have iPods
and second it would cost like 10 million
dollars and if I had 10 million dollars
I would be using it to buy an island you
could publish Paper Towns in the United
Kingdom good news on that front actually
Paper Towns will be published in the
United Kingdom by Bloomsbury books Thank
You Bloomsbury and I'm going to do my
level best to be in the UK in May of
next year John and Hank should perform a
choreographed dance to the Vanilla Ice
song Ice Ice Baby
uh hey correct me if I'm wrong here but
I think we might already have a
massively choreographed dance that we
did to Ice Ice Baby but you were about
six and I was about nine in the hazy fog
of memory I also recall that we might
have done one to the REM song stand
let's just hope those never see the
light of day John if you really want to
thank your subscribers you should say I
love you you people you tried to trick
me you tried to trick me into saying
that I love unic well I don't I don't
love them and I don't care how many
unicorn loving subscribers we get Hank
as far as I'm concerned there could be a
million unicorn lovers in nerdfighteria
and still I would say I hate unicorns
please show us the
ready show us the Yeti we've been
waiting three years let us see a picture
of the Yeti Yeti
now nerdfighters I have explained this
to you before I cannot show you a
picture of the Yeti because if I do the
cute will break your computer's and then
you'll be mad and you'll be emailing me
like I want a refund to get me back my
computer money seriously pictures of the
Yeti are more damaging than the
entertainment Infinite Jest jokes
anybody David Foster Wallace no ok
moving on you could give some money to
charity now that's an idea Willy and I
are going to give a thousand dollars to
the charity of your choice
nerdfighteria leave a comment with the
charity that you'd like Willy and me to
give money to or I guess technically the
charity to which you'd like Willy and me
to give money and now I have to go to my
personal training session so I can beat
you in whatever ridiculous fitness
challenges await us but I will see you
singing tomorrow
yes ah kiss the camera yes it s at gas
it good boy